the first seconds of your video are so
unbelievably important in terms of
giving the audience a reason to continue
to watch there's so much content out
there there's so many choices out
there's so much things that they could
watch that it's imperative that we pay
hyper close attention to those first
seconds as people are making that
decision whether or not to stay or leave
one of the kind of tactics is to
essentially repeat the title at the
beginning of the video we've been duped
by marketers so many times that kind of
the first thing you have to do is
actually be like you're in the right
place it's safe you're getting what you
were promised